[Music]
in conferences Keener's Oh
dingdong submitted by Shelley bear-like
like bingo bingo oh and save your money
views ha ding-dong
and you think I'm weird run another take
oh do you wanna keep it that's right
being dong let's go you sure you want to
redo it put your best foot forward in
the world good for her man
zoom flaws it all submitted by Shelley
bear a corporate man wears high heels to
work because they make him feel
empowered hell yeah
Prince did it first Prince did it better
I don't care what kind of high heels we
talked about pops very hot number one
and it was glitter socks I know how
yells you're a girl you should be
looking for me on those boots with a
heel on it are you kidding that's a boot
that's a pill though Jill I love you but
I don't think initiative whoa oh I'm
just kidding this art forms consider
high heels a form of yeah oh okay so
there's a form of a high heel because
your heel is a stiletto yeah if you went
sexy heels he likes to wear 6-inch
stiletto I think we're supposed to say
oh good for you guy like wow I'm like
dude that's kind of guy I was actually
here you see okay exactly I'm not even
saying it to be offensive I'm like duh I
will say this though I for some reason I
feel like high heels is like a really
great fashion statement but women I feel
like the ones that I know I've always
stated that they hated wear heels it's
all [ __ ] uncomfortable yes but they
look good they look amazing they make
you look amazing and you just feel
[ __ ] too but the legs all of it
picture all of you guys were thinking oh
this guy wants to be tall to the shore
and I'm all like not he's just gay I was
really I thought he was gay you can't
tell me I actually thought that he was a
straight business man who wears high
heels that's what I thought too see
because that would make close-minded
[ __ ] is mostly wives see
I didn't know what was going on because
I thought he was wearing a bikini
underneath the suit for some reason see
so you thought he was a crossdresser you
guys thought he was a straight guy that
was short that wanted to wear heels to
be taller and I was like he's just
straight gay
no he's just he's just a gay guy
straight gay yeah he was a straight man
can't wear high heels I agree I agree
anyone can wear whatever the [ __ ] they
want if you're going to a college party
and you're a straight guy and you're
wearing high heels and a dress that's
just hilarious right guys yeah bingo
bingo bango if you're straight and
you're wearing a dress in high heels
you're Jaden Smith that's a Halloween
costume you're doing a bit you're doing
not that's me agent mom there you go
or it's like good it's like kids in the
hall
we ran Kenya you know kids in the hall
pink anyway didn't want bears it's mrs.
Doubtfire no I'm tripping that no I
don't know that one that's white chick
kids in the hall was a sketch group a
bunch of white guys who did sketches
Lorne Michaels polka in this manner can
you tell me the story please okay so
this man his name is actually as I
mentioned before he is gate he's openly
gay but uh he okay so he works in the
financial services career and this is
what he looks like and so he likes to
wear his snappy suits but then every
time he goes to meet clients he likes to
wear his six-inch heels because they
just make him feel amazed like powerful
very empowered I want to wear high heels
I would crack the [ __ ] up I mean I still
do business with them but it would be
hilarious
it does look funny I'm really confused
because it actually looks kind of cool
it does
he looks loves the contrast of like the
manly suit would like the feminine I
don't know if it looks cool but it it
looks like something
well it looks at me like um I don't know
like what I want to when I was a kid we
used to play Super Mario Brothers 3 and
in that game they had like this picture
slider thing where it's like here's a
whole picture right and then they would
slide they break it in three pieces and
slide it and you could make it like
different images and so it looks like
you matched it until the end and then
you mismatched - oops
like it just look doesn't quite it's not
quite there yeah it looks like I'm
looking at two different things yeah
yeah it doesn't look like a complete
look yeah yeah
he looks so disgruntled on the
screenshot from an interview oh there's
a bad picture of him
he he he could be a action star he looks
like atomic blonde he looks like he
knows how to walk in heels I agree if
you can walk in heels without tripping
like that by Oh me I want to see the
bloody mess in there I tried walking in
heels that [ __ ] isn't [ __ ] a [ __ ]
martial art right there
yeah where Nicky walks in heels I'm
genuinely afraid for her like a roller
[ __ ] ankle right oh dude I mean I on
our first date I like literally saved
your life not even getting you actually
go around like a cobblestone street
watch what happens hey how about one for
for London chicks man like London
nightclub life blood oh [ __ ] my friend
just came back from like a like a
two-week like UK edrick he was like in
the UK for like two weeks he was like
dude he goes do you go to like like
Europe there's not a single bad dressed
person he goes like it is a state of
homeless dude oh they have pea coats on
yeah they're like they look good really
yeah he goes from like it doesn't matter
what age you are from how young - how
old Till's like there's like fifty six
year old ladies that look [ __ ] dope
you know that's like Mary Poppins wasn't
Dick Van Dyke homeless in that movie oh
yeah he looked great a hell of a pair of
slacks yeah they were all pressed and
clean yeah yeah you look great yeah so
he got the idea I'll hold this guy you
gotta step your game up
I know like with the worst [ __ ] like
British accent ever I hope a homeless
guy right now is watching on his phone
he's like damn one step my game up I'll
go pay for some slacks yeah so actually
you got the idea of wearing high heels
when he watched a trio a French trio of
male dancers dancing and high heels on
TV and so he started thinking about it
and so he spoke to a female
Mel executive at his bank and he just
said like every time she walked into a
room like she just towered everyone and
she always and then slow she would talk
to her he would talk to her and she
would say that I was all in the shoes
like the shoes gave her so much more
confidence and so he told his manager
like some higher-up that he would be
wearing high heels from now on and so
she came back she was like well let me
first find out that this is okay cuz I
want you getting in trouble and she goes
and then he says I'm not asking for
permission I'm letting you know
oh and so he's been doing it for some
time good for him and he said like he's
just got nothing but positive feedback
from people around him being well cuz
who's gonna say negative [ __ ] they're
gonna get sued except for that correct
his own community the gay community he
says that he sucks at [ __ ] dressing
no she so they said you're so fat he
said that some some gay people have said
to me why are you wearing a heel that's
disgusting you're a man you shove it
down people's throats no wonder gays get
bashed he says his own people are saying
that so he said I reply you lost the
right to judge me when you print
yourself with it within an inch of your
life you may you may look like a
lumberjack but your tans out of a bottle
your eyebrows are plucked you go to a
barber place you never touch the power
tool in your life this is why you don't
sell gay people dude they will [ __ ]
dress you down and destroy you
I hope emblem is a rainbow and yet they
condemn others because they don't align
with their way of thinking and yes I
think I understand what they're getting
at I think it's because like it's such a
sensitive an uphill battle because like
I don't know if you guys actually have
gay friends out there but then you know
I'll ask questions cuz I'm not [ __ ]
gay so I don't know but there's like
there's like they have different so many
different terminologies for different
type of gay people like bears like
[ __ ] like grizzly bears like koala
but you know I mean all there's like
different type of turns
what's a koala bear I'm just I forgot it
was like different because believe you
oh but then there's like the cute little
ones like a friend of mine was saying
that he has like this thing about like
outlandish gay people where they just
they have to make sure everybody knows
that they're gay you know so maybe
they'll call the flamers I guess I don't
know but I guess like that maybe that's
where he's coming from but for him it's
not even that he just likes to wear
[ __ ] heels let me wear [ __ ] heels
I guess look where that guy's saying is
that you're like one of the gay people
in our community that has to shove it
down everybody's throat that's why we
always get a negative that look straight
dudes to talk about [ __ ] too much it's
the same [ __ ] it's not uses [ __ ] it
makes me laugh it's so obnoxious it's
hilarious to talk about how they eat
[ __ ] and all [ __ ] oh [ __ ] love these
guys but you know yeah it's annoying
yeah yeah
so April what do you think about that
one hey dude you're [ __ ] annoying
yeah yeah like you're picking from a
menu but like you get lucky like it's
all-you-can-eat exactly
yeah I don't care what he wears if he
does good work I work with them oh [ __ ]
like I actually would like that I'll be
like yo check it out this is my
stockbroker yeah he's a clown like he
comes in look what it's like y'all man
he [ __ ] hooks me up he made me like
15 percent last year dude yeah exactly
you know I mean like just like Peter Pan
if you make me more money they don't
[ __ ] like I go to my doctor he's a
[ __ ] pirate has an eyepatch harder
and I'm like yo you're not gonna use
that hook right yeah like you know yeah
it definitely must be weird because like
I think when a group is trying to come
up and then you have like an internal
drama like that it makes it like oh [ __ ]
like we're just a cannibalizing each
other at this point yeah yeah but what
group agrees on any that's true you wait
yeah you know excited a whole bunch of
Asian people yeah dude they bunch us up
into one group and [ __ ] the Asian
American I'm like dude shut the [ __ ] up
only I speak for everybody
[Laughter]
represent mine represent yours I know
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's true that's all I'd
love to see that in real life whether
like interview some Asian American you
know what the best like this is much of
a [ __ ] to represent us I see that
[ __ ] key and Peele
where it's like the like gay people are
allowed to get married it's like two
couples it's like [ __ ] keegan-michael
key and Jordan Peele
he's like yes we could get me we're
getting married because we're not really
sure about that yet he goes yeah I love
but he was like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah okay Ashley does say like he
doesn't wear them day in and day out
because they do get uncomfortable of
course they look on couples [ __ ] but he
will always wear them whenever he meets
new clients because it's a great
conversation starter cool good business
kind of hard to ignore that was my
favorite gay gay marriage joke argument
like dad joke argument was like the
whole like they they have a right to be
miserable too
[Music]